[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est sens
public 90 minutes de débats et de
reportage comme tous les jours du lundi
au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur public c'est
la 90 minutes deux grands thèmes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité et vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société et pour
ouvrir cette émission c'est un chiffre
que je vous propose 17 comme le nombre
de motion de censure déposés contre la
première ministre en un peu plus d'un an
c'est un record dans l'histoire de la
Cinquième République la dernière en date
initiée par la nupes a été rejetée sans
surprise hier Elisabeth borne la
résiliente va-t-elle pour autant
survivre à l'été les tractations qui
continuent entre Emmanuel Macron et les
LR peuvent-ils peuvent-elles aboutir à
un pacte de gouvernement on en débat
juste après ces titres et puis c'était
une promesse électorale du candidat à
Macron au printemps 2022 accordé le RSA
le revenu de solidarité active sous
condition la réforme est aujourd'hui
testée dans 18 départements avec 15 à 20
heures de programme d'insertion proposé
aux bénéficiaire
nous avec les entreprises avec les
différents partenaires et qui qui sont
aujourd'hui un peu sur notre autorité à
réaliser au niveau de la région mais on
va les accompagner pour retourner à
l'emploi il faut savoir qu'on a quand
même 157 métiers en tension dans
l'hôtellerie dans le BTP et qu'il faut
absolument travailler avec ces métiers
ce RSA sous conditions peut-il faciliter
le retour à l'emploi il subit en tout
cas les critiques de plusieurs
associations et parties de gauche qui
parlent de culpabilisation des
bénéficiaires assistanat insertion plein
emploi ce seront les grands thèmes de
notre second débat dans trois quarts
d'heure ça promet d'être passionnant
mais d'abord cette page qui se tourne
dans le second quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron le président a réussi à faire
passer sa réforme des retraites mais sa
majorité et son gouvernement sont
toujours aussi fragiles Flora sauvage
sans surprise les députés ont rejeté
hier la motion de censure contre la
réforme des retraites clôturant la
bataille contre le projet phare du
gouvernement alors que la fin de la
période des 100 jours fixée par Emmanuel
Macron arrive à son terme depuis
l'éventualité d'un remaniement se
précise la majorité présidentielle
réfléchit à un rapprochement avec la
droite ce qui laisse les sécateurs LR
sceptiques un accord a du sens si jamais
on connaît la ligne politique les
réformes qui veulent être conduites et
effectivement si c'est des réformes qui
nous agréent qui vont dans le sens de la
France pourquoi pas mais aujourd'hui il
y a pas vraiment de de lignes politiques
on passe d'un sujet à un autre soucieux
de connaître les intentions de LR
Emmanuel Macron s'est entretenu à
l'Élysée avec Nicolas Sarkozy il y a
quelques jours pour l'ancien chef de
l'État il faut un premier ministre de
droite en 2007 le président Sarkozy ne
veut pas passer l'accord avec le Parti
socialiste il avait picoré au sein du PS
et pris ceux qui étaient les plus
populaires il pourra jamais y avoir
d'accord avec un parti le président peut
choisir qu'il souhaite pour une nouvelle
donne au sein de la majorité
présidentielle on se méfie d'une droite
qui ne répond plus à un chef unique et
on avance les pions d'un remaniement je
rappelle que un ministre de toute façon
c'était éphémère comme comme fonction la
question du casting n'est pas primordial
concrètement je pense que ce qui est
important c'est le portage politique
c'est ce qu'on fait c'est comment est-ce
qu'on met en application le programme
présidentiel sur fond de remaniement la
fébrilité gagne les ministères reste la
question du maintien ou non d'Elizabeth
borne à Matignon
Emmanuel Macron peut-il se passer DLR
dans le cadre d'un remaniement c'est la
question principale il y en aura
quelques autres que je vous propose dans
ce débat avec Lucile Schmitt bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes membre de la
rédaction de la revue Esprit et
co-auteur de ce livre Emmanuel Macron a
contretemps publié aux éditions Bayard
Bruno contrez bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes politologue chercheur au cnrso
c'est vipov j'accueille également
Jean-Sébastien Ferjoux bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous fondateur et directeur
d'Atlantico Laetitia cruppa bonsoir
Laetitia éditorialiste politique ce
chapitre de la réforme des retraites il
se referme donc avec les chèques de
cette motion de censure déposée par la
nups hier lucide schmitts obstacle on
peut dire maintenant qu'il a été évité
ou sauté par Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement
non sans mal et non sans conséquence
politique à moyen ou long terme on peut
certainement dire ça que dire de la
nouvelle phase qui s'ouvre elle est pas
pour autant dégager d'embûches c'est
c'est la moindre des expressions c'est à
dire que une fois que comme vous dites
certaines embûches sont passées on se
retrouve devant la question de remplir
de contenu une période qui pour
l'instant dans la plus c'est à dire
qu'on s'est tellement habitué à regarder
cette question des oppositions à la
réforme des retraites dans la rue la
société mobilisée au Parlement c'est que
maintenant il y a plus ça et que du coup
ça oblige à regarder la façon dont
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui manque d'un
CAP dont d'une certaine manière
d'ailleurs ceux qui l'entourent disent
tout et son contraire et puis cette
question d'Elisabeth borne qui est
agitée sur la question du remaniement
les 17 motions de censure moi je vous
l'aurais quand même dire qu'on ne
démonétise pas si vite quelque chose
qu'on nous a présenté il y a un an comme
une espèce de d'immense rupture il
fallait nommer une femme première
ministre il fallait nommer une femme
première ministre de gauche il fallait
nommer de quelqu'un de compétences sur
la question écologique la planification
écologique et donc tout ça en annonce ce
serait totalement démonétisé alors qu'il
faut faire la transition écologique
donner évidemment aux femmes en
politique de l'importance et peut-être
éviter de faire à droite toute d'une
manière aussi claire que ça si on ne
veut pas d'une certaine manière offrir
peut-être un cadeau aussi à LR qui pour
l'instant je le rappelle n'a que environ
80 députés
évidemment sur l'avenir de d'Elisabeth
mais c'est alors c'était sans doute
mission impossible mais Emmanuel Macron
lui avait donné on s'en souvient 100
jours on était à un mois de l'échéance
il y avait quoi il y avait deux
principales on va dire dans la feuille
de route il y avait deux lignes
principales
[Musique]
élargir sa majorité renouer le dialogue
du syndicat bon pour le bilan c'est
c'est effectivement pas pas du tout fait
Yanni élargissement de la majorité et on
voit que c'est quand même un problème
qui devient maintenant un vrai problème
structurant régulier pour l'exécutif qui
n'arrivent pas à faire passer ses
projets en dehors de l'utilisation
d'instruments législatif qui font des
bas dans l'opinion
en eau assez basse 25% à peu près pour
un an de mandats c'est quand même pas
terrible et
image d'ensemble dans l'opinion qui
n'arrivent pas pour le moment à incarner
quelque chose qui soit aussi important
que les prédécesseurs parce que ce que
j'entends c'est qu'on a l'impression que
le temps est presque un peu suspendu
est-ce que vous ressentez ça aussi
Jean-Sébastien fairejoux espèce de creux
là de
suspendu ou si on est dans une impasse
qu'on peut continuer à pousser plus loin
l'impasse mais on y est me semble-t-il
depuis les législatives 2022 Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas compris la nouvelle donne
politique on n'avait pas encore éprouvé
ça une majorité relative Michel Rocard
avait connu mais il manquait quand même
très peu de voix pour réussir à faire
passer et à l'époque on pouvait utiliser
autant de fois le 49-3 d'ailleurs qu'on
veut pendant pendant une session
parlementaire mais il s'avère que avec
une majorité relative nous ne sommes
plus dans un régime présidentiel mais
dans un régime parlementaire il continue
à se comporter comme s'il était le
président à la tête d'institution
présidentielle ça n'est pas le cas et
donc la feuille de route nous a donné à
Elisabeth borne était TopShot parce que
c'est une feuille d'autre qui s'inscrit
justement dans une la vision d'un régime
présidentiel là où un régime
parlementaire c'est autre chose c'est un
esprit de coalition pour rebondir ce que
vous disiez à limite peu importe que les
LR soient 65 45 72 vous voyez non mais
ce que j'ai c'est comme si les Français
avaient forcé une fois une part de
proportionnelle vous voyez bien qu'en
Israël en partie qui a deux députés peut
être un parti pivoter ce sont les deux
députés dont vous avez pas du tout cette
construction
ce n'est pas la seule réponse d'Emmanuel
Macron absolument personne ne l'a
intégré ni le président de la République
ni en face les oppositions qui
d'ailleurs jouent à faire comme si une
alternance était apportée de l'amant ce
qu'on peut faire autant de mentions de
son ou ils peuvent essayer de faire
voter autant de mentions de censure
qu'ils veulent il n'y a pas de majorité
alternative il y avait une majorité de
rejets de la réforme des retraite il y a
pas de majorité alternative mais c'est
là où je pense que peut-être la pièce
est en l'air et que on est dans
l'impasse mais parce qu'on voit que je
pense qu'il y a même Macron a fini par
intégrer cette donne là il a fini par
comprendre quand même l'état de
faiblesse politique dans laquelle il se
trouvait et probablement les autres en
fait aussi en tout cas les républicains
l'ont compris et donc ceux qui le
rejetaient obstinément il y a un an il y
avait que Nicolas Sarkozy qu'il
proposait de dire il faut prendre
finalement comme il y aura pas de
troisième mandat d'Emmanuel Macron il
faut pirater le macronisme de
l'intérieur je pense que là certains ça
commence à infuser des européennes ou
ils se disent si ça se trouve on sera
moins de 5 % on n'aura pas de députés et
donc l'avenir pourrait l'air en tant que
territoire politique autonome il est de
plus en plus haute cursif et il n'y
croit pas vraiment eux-mêmes alors vous
avez lancé les ajouts dans la parole
tout de suite les grands thèmes on y
reviendra évidemment un peu plus en
détail j'ai juste vous avez posé la
question de la responsabilité il me
semble quand vous écoutez en Bruno
cotreesse et vous Jean Sébastien faire
jouer effectivement c'était la question
qui me venait naturellement c'est à dire
que c'est un problème structurant pour
l'exécutif vous avez raison une impasse
vous dites mais c'est aussi une
gigantesque opportunité pour les
oppositions qui pour l'instant
n'existaient pas qui n'existe encore que
très peu finalement dans l'opinion
publique Bruno kotresse
aussi à
c'est ça c'est à dire on voit
effectivement du côté de la stratégie
des DLR c'est cette idée progressivement
qui fait jour qui est de dire et bien on
va leur faire le coup qui nous ont fait
au fond en 2017 et on va se réinstaller
chez nous à l'intérieur du macronisme en
faire quelque chose et puis du côté
voilà exactement la fameuse stratégie du
coup et puis à gauche on voit qu'à
gauche quand même de fortes tensions qui
est sur le cette question stratégique le
centre gauche doit-il être son boîtier
de son avenir à l'intérieur de laupes ou
peut-il reprendre un petit peu espoir
mais après
juste d'un mot qui surplombe tout ça et
qui donne cette impression d'impasse
c'est qu'il y a ces considérations
d'institutions de régimes de pratiques
des institutions mais il y a aussi une
absence de contenu politique mais aussi
bien pour le macronisme que finalement
les oppositions que vous évoquez la
transition écologique mais personne n'a
véritablement formulé une offre qui dise
comment en s'inscrit dans la démocratie
libérale avec quelque chose d'assez
ambitieux volontaire et certains même
proposent des solutions autoritaires et
personne n'a là-dessus et on entend
plutôt des discours contradictoires et
on peut décliner cette question là sur
d'autres sujets je pense que vraiment au
discours vraiment au niveau métal
politique il y a plus de vision c'est ça
aussi cette sensation collectif est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça et
ensuite on ouvre un nouveau chapitre moi
ce qui me frappe c'est que ce débat sur
régime présidentiel régime parlementaire
c'est presque un débat de de droit mais
dans la pratique ce qui me semble clair
c'est que depuis un an nous avons été à
la fois déçus par le Président de la
République et par le Parlement c'est à
dire que nous avons vu en tout cas à
l'Assemblée nationale des oppositions
souvent 17 motions de censure en sachant
qu'aucune n'a été gagné ça signifie de
l'acharnement et ça signifie une
incapacité à créer de la coalition et
donc non mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que nous sommes dans une situation
où même si les institutions étaient plus
parlementaires il n'y a pas de culture
parlementaire du côté des oppositions et
par rapport à ce que vous venez de dire
sur le fait qu'il y a un boulevard pour
les oppositions peut-être mais enfin ça
fait un bout de temps qu'on le dit et au
contraire je trouve que ces oppositions
ni à droite ni à gauche ne sont saisis
veut dire que y compris alors le RN le
sujet c'est que on peut pas continuer à
se taire pendant 5 ans et que ils ont
pour l'instant joué la montre mais qui a
un moment il faut sortir du bois et ce
qui est clair c'est que pour l'instant
c'est LR qui sort du bois pour le RN
avec la loi migratoire mais que du coup
cette question du vide elle saisit à la
fois le président son camp et aussi les
oppositions me semble-t-il alors cette
motion de censure donc rejetée hier à
l'Assemblée je propose de revoir la
séquence ce moment où la présidentielle
Braun pivée annonce les résultats la
séance est reprise voici le résultat du
scrutin majorité requise pour l'adoption
de la motion de censure soit la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 239 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée la
séance est levée pour une minutes le
temps d'un changement de perchoir
changement de perchoir à l'Assemblée
entrez le six Jourdain sur le plateau
sur le public bienvenue à vous on aurait
tort de banaliser cette cette motion de
ceinture c'est succession émotion oui
Thomas pour une raison simple et
Isabelle borne est la première ministre
qui a dû affronter le plus de motions de
censure de l'histoire de la 5e
République 17 à son compteur à la
relance parle loin très loin devant
Georges Pompidou Premier ministre de 62
à 68 et qui avait vu lui cette motion de
censure déposée contre lui l'une d'elles
avait d'ailleurs été adoptée la seule à
ce jour c'était en 1968 et les députés
protestaient alors contre l'introduction
du suffrage universel pour l'élection du
Président de la République au classement
des premiers ministres on trouve aussi
Pierre Mauroy Premier ministre
socialiste de 80 à 84 cette motion
contre lui tout comme Raymond Barre
Premier ministre de 76 à 81 plus bas
dans le classement il y a Michel Rocard
chef du gouvernement de 88 à 91 il a dû
subir lui la fronde d'une partie des
députés à six reprises en trois ans il y
a motion de censure émotion de censure
il existe deux types de motions celles
qui sont dites spontanées et celles qui
sont provoquées l'émotion spontanée sont
à l'initiative des députés 58 élus
déposent un texte pour renverser le
gouvernement l'émotion provoquée elle
font suite à l'utilisation de l'article
49-3 par le Premier ministre qui décide
d'engager la responsabilité du
Gouvernement sur un texte précis alors
on sait un qu-elisabeth borne à utiliser
cette procédure à 11 reprises en un an à
chaque fois elle a dû affronter la
défiance d'une partie des députés
c'était par exemple le cas au mois de
mars au moment de l'adoption de la
réforme des retraites elle dénoncée
alors l'anti parlementarisme de la
France insoumise écoutez là dans un
déchaînement de violence comme cette
hémicycle en a peu connu sous la
Cinquième République
certains élus de la nation ont une
nouvelle fois montré le peu de cas qu'il
faisait du débat du Parlement de la
démocratie c'était le paroxysme de
semaine entière durant lesquels au cœur
même du Parlement nous avons vu l'anti
parlementarisme à l'oeuvre sous toutes
ses facettes à l'époque il avait manqué
9 fois à le pour renverser le
gouvernement neuf petites voix que
n'avaient alors pas souhaité donner les
députés LR il faut rappeler que sur les
17 motions déposées contre Elisabeth
borne aucune ne l'a été à l'initiative
des républicains aucune pour l'instant
les LR voudront peut-être aussi jouer
avec les nerfs du gouvernement au moment
de l'examen du texte immigration prévu à
l'automne ça pourrait être l'occasion
pourquoi pas de mettre un peu la
pression sur l'exécutif justement et
puis votre langue est fourchée
évidemment 1962 1962 évidemment
l'introduction de Bercy s'il va tout à
l'heure pour notre second débat on va
revenir sur sur
l'aspect loi immigration parce que je
trouve que c'est un chapitre intéressant
mais je voudrais puisqu'on est dans
cette mécanique d'émotions de censure
cette succession de motion de censure
déposée contre Elisabeth borne écoutez
là hier quand elle défend son
gouvernement la première ministre
certains ici semblent convaincus que le
courage politique c'est une opposition
vocale caricaturale totale moi je ne
confonds pas le courage et les décibels
le vrai courage politique c'est de
sortir du confort de la posture de la
course au petites phrases de construire
des majorités même avec ceux qui ne
pensent pas exactement comme nous
les défis qui nous attendent sont d'une
ampleur immense nous devons trouver la
force collective pour les relevés voilà
bon il y a toujours ce on en parlait
juste avant ce rêve de de d'avoir la
capacité à créer une majorité ou des
majorités cas par cas même si elle y a
réussi sur certains textes quand même 17
motions de censure elle se serait
certainement passer de ce record elle
risque de de l'améliorer c'est ça va
être le Novak djokovitch de la politique
si ça continue non mais sérieusement
est-ce que ça fait d'elle une
personnalité politique résiliente est-ce
que ça peut la servir pour l'instant
elle a du mal à imprimer dans le pignon
est-ce que ça peut la servir à terme
dans le pignon des français ce qui est
intéressant quand on l'écoutière on voit
qu'effectivement elle use elle utilise
un peu ce ressort c'est un politique
quand même on a beau dire c'est une
technocrate mais une dimension politique
chez elle et donc elle sait utiliser ce
ressort parce qu'effectivement elle est
en train progressivement de de prendre
ce rôle qui est celle qui est résilient
tout le monde l'attaque tout le monde
est injuste avec elle et elle elle tient
bon et on a vu hier en particulier
qu'elle venait sur un vocabulaire et sur
des thèmes qui sont très importants aux
yeux des macronistes elle opposait au
fond les oppositions qui sont des
démagogues des idéologues dit-elle qui
ne pensent pas d'intérêt national qui ne
pense qu'à leur petite boutique et elle
qui s'érige en
défenseur de l'intérêt national elle
utilise hier à une expression
extrêmement intéressante le courage de
faire la volonté d'agir et ces deux
verbes faire agir sont devenait qui à
l'intérieur de la macronie sont
absolument essentiel puisque dès le
début dès 2016-2017 Emmanuel Macron nous
explique que lui ce qu'il veut et bien
c'est réunir les bonnes volontés pour
réformer enfin la France pour sortir des
ornières des clivages et des idéologies
et ces deux verbes sont deux verbes qui
sont très souvent utilisés dans les
enquêtes de pians quand on demande au
macroniste qu'il pense d'Emmanuel Macron
ils vont beaucoup utiliser ce registre
il est celui qui a le courage
de vouloir réformer un pays impossible à
réformer il essaye contre vent et marée
et il est celui qui incarne le fait
d'agir concrètement c'est vrai que Jean
Sébastien il va je le dis en titre il va
sans doute Emmanuel Macron payer
politiquement électoralement enfin en
tout cas où c'est où ces soutiens les
conséquences de cette réforme de
retraite mais enfin il a aussi en partie
consolider un socle électoral il y a une
partie de l'opinion publique française
qui sondage après sondage soutenaient
cette réforme des retraites
oui mais il a son socle électoral qui
est resté relativement stable et
d'ailleurs plus stable probablement que
ces prédécesseurs sur son cœur
d'électorat à lui mais après ça n'est
pas une majorité de Français et c'est
très marqué sociologiquement malgré tout
notamment avec avec les retraités mais
le problème c'est qu'on parlait de faire
réagir oui c'est très important dans le
logiciel macronien et dans le
vocabulaire mais c'est de plus en plus
déconnecté du réel c'est à dire que
l'émotion de censure je pense qu'une
écrasante majorité de Français si on
sortait dans la rue et on leur demandait
que s'est-il passé hier à l'Assemblée
nationale je suis sûr que vraiment très
peu de gens suivent encore alors qu'en
1962 c'était un événement c'était le
summum d'une crise qui produisait des
effets politiques
lourds et c'est de plus en plus
décorrélé mais aussi bien et je rejoins
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure de la
part du gouvernement comme de la part
des oppositions comme de la part des
oppositions et donc on a des débats
publics qui sont de plus en plus
hors-sol avec des Français qui eux on
peut sur leur dire faire ou agir ou
faire la révolution qui on écoute la
nuque eux qu'est-ce qu'ils voient ils
voient que quand ils vont à l'hôpital et
ben ils n'ont pas de place pour passer
aux urgences il voit que les écoles
elles fonctionnent de moins en moins il
voit que la police n'a pas forcément les
moyens de ces missions et que les
problèmes de sécurité se multiplient
dans le pays et cette déconnexion entre
parce que dire faisons-le à la limite je
veux dire qu'on prenne comme Elizabeth
borne des majorités de bonnes intentions
ou de bonnes volonté ou on est dans
l'opposition absolue à l'arrivée ce qui
compte c'est quand même le réel et là
sur le réel plus grand chose ne se passe
justement
cette notion de réel
moi je crois pas dans le diagnostic ça
fait longtemps qu'il en est crédité en
tout cas sur une partie mais après il
sait marcher sur des gens Marine Le Pen
avait une intelligence d'être la
première à parler vraiment d'inflation
je me souviens d'ailleurs du débat
d'entre-deux-tours lui avait répondu du
haut de sa compétence à lui qu'elle se
trompait sur les chiffres l'expérience à
montrer qu'elle avait totalement raison
sur les chiffres et lui pour le coup
avait tort elle est sociale elle a la
sécurité après je pense que le RN pour
des tas de raisons après ce sera un
autre débat mais aussi bien historique
idéologique que humaine en fait liée à
la sociologie de ce parti-là et aux
compétences qui s'y trouve une s'y
trouvent pas je reste persuadé qu'il y a
un plafond de verre sur ce parti le
sépare encore vraiment de la marche
ultime avec une thématique qui est
tellement intégrée par l'électorat ARN
qu'elle a quasiment plus besoin d'en
parler Marine Le Pen c'est la thématique
de l'immigration j'aurais qu'on consacre
un chapitre aux enjeux autour de la loi
immigration Lucy Schmidt parce que c'est
une carte dans le jeu des LR pour mettre
la pression sur le gouvernement là on
est dans le dans le jeu politique après
aussi le fond de cette réforme et ça
c'est important vouliez en parler oui
j'avais envie d'en parler parce que moi
j'ai travaillé à un moment sur les
questions migratoires et ce que
j'observe c'est que depuis une vingtaine
d'années il y a une sorte d'incapacité à
dire par la loi justement vous parliez
du réel la réalité la situation
migratoire qui est d'abord qu'il y a
plusieurs types de catégories on le sait
il y a des demandeurs d'asile des
réfugiés il y a des migrants économiques
il y a des sans-papiers parfois les
sans-papiers sont en fait des migrants
économiques et donc récupère des papiers
et au fond ce qui était intéressant dans
le projet de loi que voulait présent on
nous rebat les oreilles sans le
présenter d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
ça qui est important du côté du
gouvernement c'était l'idée qu'on
pouvait associer la discussion sur les
différentes catégories de migration et
en fait revenir sur la question de
l'attractivité économique aussi la
question sociale la question du
regroupement familial le fait de dire au
fond que les migrants sont des personnes
et puis par ailleurs être plus ferme sur
les conditions d'accès à notre
territoire donc on envisageait
délinquance le lien avec la criminalité
ou c'est tabou ça c'est pas un tabou
mais c'est en tout cas une question qui
pour l'instant est resté par le
rassemblement national et l'aborder sous
forme de slogans et de et reprendre par
exemple les slogans du rassemblement
national sans vérifier ce qu'on dit ça
me semble être un problème donc le sujet
qui était intéressant c'est que au moins
le gouvernement associait la migration à
la question à une complexité équilibre
il y avait un équilibre il y avait
peut-être l'idée de rattraper le réel
parce que le sujet de l'équilibre
politique au Parlement n'est pas le
sujet du réel et au fond les Français
savent que sur la question migratoire la
réalité de ce qu'ils vivent on l'a vu
d'ailleurs au moment du confinement
lorsqu'on a eu des boulangers lorsqu'on
a eu un certain nombre d'artisans qui au
fond en plaider pour les sans-papiers en
disant là il y a un sujet d'emploi et on
l'a vu aussi par rapport je termine
juste parce que c'est un sujet assez
passionnant on le voit aussi
régulièrement lorsqu'on nous dit il y a
de très bons élèves qui sont sans
papiers donc il y a un sujet autour de
la migration que les Français envisagent
indépendamment j'allais dire de du
discours du discours
politicien et moi je me rappelle aussi
quand même je le répète souvent mais que
Gérald Darmanin osé dire à Marine Le Pen
qu'elle était molle sur la question
migratoire donc on voit bien aussi au
fond de majorité qui cherche sa boutique
de la démonstration vous craignez si je
comprends bien sous le titre que
finalement sous la pression DLR le texte
droitise encore encore je crains que
sous la pression des lèvres en tout cas
on aille sur le slogan politique et non
pas sur la réalité des faits et je
crains que ça soit un énième texte le
fond ne débouchera pas sur une meilleure
maîtrise des flux migratoires et que une
nouvelle fois du coup on se trouve face
à des faits de réalité en réalité oui en
fait
à considérer qu'une loi pourrait gérer
c'est l'âge je ne sais combien de mois
35e ou 72e ou 2018 je sais plus le
chiffre mais quoi qu'il en soit on en a
voté beaucoup sur les 30 dernières
années et ça ne peut pas permettre de
gérer le réel déjà parce qu'il y a une
question de volonté politique une
question de volonté politique au niveau
européen sur la question du droit
d'asile notamment ça n'a pas de sens
qu'on est des règles différentes selon
les états alors que une fois que vous
avez obtenu l'Asie dans un état européen
vous pouvez des facto circuler au sein
de cet espace là il y a une question de
sociologie aussi dans des cours par
exemple d'appels qui statuts sur vous
avez un certain nombre de gens qui sont
militants par exemple il y a des gens
qui vont se voir accorder l'asile en
France alors qu'ils ont séjourné dans
des camps d'Al-Qaïda ça c'est un fait il
y a aussi une question sociologique
parce que voilà et cette question de
volonté politique là après je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est une question
complexe et je pense que les Français
sont d'ailleurs assez contradictoires
dans parce qu'ils sont capables
d'imaginer le migrant comme en individu
et c'est normal et bien sûr que ce sont
des êtres humains et comme le boulanger
qui connaissent ou comme le camarade
d'école de leurs enfants qui connaissent
ou comme leur nounou qui veulent faire
régulariser bref et après il imagine
aussi comme un flux il y a un moment
peut-être une société qui sait faire
preuve de maturité politique on ne peut
pas avoir tout et son contraire et soit
on choisit une posture de générosité
soit on choisit une posture de maîtrise
mais il faut savoir choisir
juste un petit mot presque un tac au tac
par rapport à ce que vous dites je crois
que le problème c'est qu'effectivement
il y a des enjeux de sécurité sur la
question migratoire on le sait mais il y
a aussi des enjeux humanitaires et
aujourd'hui la vérité c'est que comme on
ne sait pas très bien traiter toujours
les enjeux sécuritaires on laisse en
fait dans une sorte de couloir d'attente
des gens qui sont depuis 10 ans en
France qui ont un emploi etc et
intégration qui sont quand même de
sujets je pense que quand on est migrant
et qu'on est depuis 10 ans en France on
a envisagé une forme d'intégration et
puis des défauts d'intégration
du fait que on sait qu'aujourd'hui
auprès des préfets dans le auprès des se
fait à la régularisation selon la
personne sur laquelle vous tombez vous
pouvez être régularisé ou pas donc il y
a pas de véritable lois nationales et ça
ça crée un certain nombre de difficultés
par des associations ça peut aider mais
en tout cas à la question du service
public et du droit des étrangers dans ce
pays n'est pas au produit à son bon
niveau et l'autre sur cette question je
reviens à la aux enjeux beaucoup plus
politiques parce que derrière cette loi
immigration il y a effectivement la
question dont on parle dans ce débat
d'une éventuelle alliance entre les LR
et la macronie et à l'occasion de la
motion de censure évidemment on a
entendu ressortir dans les arguments du
rassemblement national cette attaque de
la roue de secours du gouvernement
écoutez le député RN de la Moselle
Laurent jacobelli écoutez les
républicains vont à nouvelle une
nouvelle fois trahir leur électeurs ils
vont être à nouveau la roue de secours
d'une macronie en perte de vitesse je
crois que ils ont envoyé un double
signal aujourd'hui on entend très peu
présent et en montrant qu'il ne voterait
pas la motion de censure c'est que
définitivement ils ne sont plus dans
l'opposition mais dans la majorité et
j'aurais qu'on parle d'un éventuel
remaniement et venir à la question
centrale de notre débat Emmanuel Macron
peut-il se passer des bonsault sait-on
des tractations nos confrères de
L'Express dis qu'il y a eu un
rendez-vous secret entre Emmanuel Macron
et et Nicolas Sarkozy qu'est-ce qu'on
sait de ces tractations ce qui est
certain est beaucoup de signaux vont
dans ce sens là ce qui est certain c'est
que la majorité peut pas rester pendant
quatre ans dans les situations que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui on veut pas
continuer à avoir imaginons
l'ensemble des lois de finances qui
auraient été adoptées aux 49-3 sous un
quinquennat il y a quand même un moment
donné un sujet de bonne démocratie ce
sont des outils législatifs qui sont
destinés à être utilisés de manière un
peu exceptionnelle ça peut pas devenir
l'ordinaire du gouvernement sur des
sujets fondamentaux bien évidemment donc
c'est certain qu'il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose du point de vue DLR on
voit il y a quelque chose aussi
effectivement il semble peut-être un peu
plus intéressé de rejoindre la majorité
qu'auparavant mais ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment délicat c'est que chacun d'une
certaine manière un peu des des
pions à pousser ça ne veut pas dire que
nécessairement ça va déboucher sur une
coalition on voit que du côté des DLR ça
permet d'exister à nouveau de manière
forte de se situer au centre du jeu
politique et surtout de planter le
drapeau à nouveau sur des thèmes que les
LR considèrent comme leurs propriétés la
question de l'immigration avec à travers
toujours la question d'immigration de la
question de la souveraineté nationale la
question d'identité donc il plante le
drapeau pour rappeler qu'ils sont là du
côté de la majorité ça montre que on a
envie de bouger mais en même temps si
par exemple ça échoué sur la question de
l'immigration ça permet à la majorité de
dire bah vous voyez tout le monde dit
qu'on est de droite ben non on n'est pas
autant de droite avec les questions
on se demande pour qui parce qu'ils sont
où aujourd'hui les électeurs LR
pour cranter à nouveau vis-à-vis des
lecteurs républicains qui ont envie que
leur mouvement politique leur envoie des
signaux des balises quelque part les
républicains vont devoir réexister sur
la question de l'économie puis on se
rapprochera de 2027 plus les
républicains vont commencer à dire la
dette les impôts le nombre de
fonctionnaires sur l'économie
ils seront obligés immigration
identité nationale il se rappelle au bon
souvenir de tout le monde en disant
c'est chez nous avec une question
Jean-Sébastien Ferjoux quand je disais
le le papier de nos confrères de
L'Express je me disais mais sur qui
Nicolas Sarkozy a le plus influence
est-ce que sur ces c'est sur les LR ou
est-ce que c'est sur Emmanuel Macron
probablement mais quoi qu'il en soit il
y avait la stratégie Nicolas Sarkozy qui
a quand même parlé à quelques députés LR
mais elle était rejetée globalement par
les autres parce que ceux des députés LR
qui ont survécu les législatives de 2022
ont été élus dans des circonscriptions
qui sociologiquement les ancrés vraiment
dans l'opposition c'était un électorat
de droite qui se vivait comme en
opposition au macronisme donc les autres
humainement ne s'imaginaient pas
s'inscrire là donc et en plus se sentait
trahi par Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait pas
soutenu Valérie
c'est-à-dire que les mêmes députés ont
fini par rater et probablement aussi
ceux qui sont à la tête du parti on
finit par acter leur faiblesse
c'est-à-dire ou prendre conscience de
leur faiblesse et prendre conscience que
leur destin autonome n'était pas la
meilleure garantie de revenir au pouvoir
il y a une vraie inquiétude par rapport
aux élections européennes certains se
disent potentiellement si on fait moins
de 5% nous n'avons plus parlementaire
c'est quand même très dur pour un parti
dit de gouvernement et que je sais faire
que ce qui s'est passé pendant le
premier quinquennat je pense c'est
d'ailleurs un peu le péché originel le
débauchage individuel d'Edouard Philippe
de Gérald Darmanin Bruno Le Maire c'est
un apporte rien strictement rien il y a
pas d'accord politique François
bayrousse c'est un accord politique il
apporte d'ailleurs c'est lui qui fait
basculer il apporte un électorat et une
vision politique prise en compte dans le
macronisme les autres n'apportent
strictement rien il faudrait là ce que
se disent les LR c'est qu'ils veulent
pas débauchages personnel c'est pas pour
mettre un ou deux ou trois ministres en
plus
tourner le cap de l'avion c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure pour
pirater le truc de l'intérieur parce que
il y a la question de 2027 et pour le
récupérer en se disant ben finalement on
n'y croit plus par l'extérieur on va
essayer par la fesse Nord sauf que qui
est capable parce que je rejoins la
question des chats qui est capable de le
faire est-ce que Gérard Larcher est
capable de réunir une majorité députés
LR à l'Assemblée nationale moi je ne
crois pas et après on voit bien qu'il y
a plutôt une sensibilité je sais pas
quoi Pradier Bertrand un peu plus social
une sensibilité un peu plus évoquée
alors lequel de tous ces noms là est-ce
que finalement moi j'ai j'imagine que
Laurent Wauquiez c'était montré beaucoup
moins offensif dans sa dernière
interview ce qui est quand même un vrai
vrai changement de pied ça c'est
intéressant avec un risque quand même
pour Emmanuel Macron c'est que s'il
nomme un Premier ministre
issu de LR il se coupe de de sa majorité
modèle ou centre gauche il y a quand
même ce risque là pour le président le
sujet c'est plutôt que qu'est-ce que
c'est que LR c'est à dire que on l'a vu
au moment de la la primaire on l'a vu au
moment du débat sur les retraites
aujourd'hui imaginez qu'on ait une
famille politique rassemblée derrière un
seul homme on sait que ça n'existe pas à
droite comme à gauche d'ailleurs et à
partir de là moi je pense que tout
dépend de la personne qu'on envisage
c'est à dire que il est clair que par
exemple Xavier Bertrand une certaine
manière il aurait intérêt à aller à
Matignon parce que lui il pourrait mener
étant donné qu'on le qualifie de fibres
sociales il pourrait mener cette espèce
d'élargissement de la droite vers la
gauche Macron avait fait l'élargissement
de la gauche vers la droite et là il est
au dans une impasse parce qu'il est
tellement vers la droite puis par
ailleurs il se représentera que il faut
trouver un successeur on voit que
Edouard Philippe nous explique
maintenant qu'il faut dénoncer l'accord
avec l'Algérie parce que justement la
question migratoire est devenue le
marqueur qui peut-être permettra d'aller
plus loin et par rapport à ce que vous
disiez sur le fait que le débauchage
individuel ne rapporte rien le
débauchage individuel rapporte des
électeurs il ne rapporte rien en terme
parlementaire ou par rapport à un accord
de un accord mais encore une fois en
France on n'est pas en Allemagne on
n'est pas avec des accords politiques
qu'on tient de 300 pages et qu'on
négocie pendant 6 mois quand on fait un
accord de gouvernement moi j'ai du mal à
croire qu'ils tiennent et je pense qu'il
tient souvent sur le fait de nommer un
tel ou un tel plutôt que sur le contenu
donc je pense que cette question d'aller
et c'est toute la question est encore
vivable
je pense que ni Olivier marleixiotti ne
sont ceux qui nommeront quelqu'un à
Matignon et que ça sera toujours du
débauchage individuel alors cette
question d'un accord qui qui peut tenir
pour la balance ça vaut aussi pour un
nouveau parti politique Laetitia on va
parler de la nuque ou de la nupesse pour
vous la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale c'est fini oui
c'est fini c'est pas moi qui le dit
Thomas si on est bien attentif à ce qui
est sorti dans les médias c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le Créateur Celui qui a eu
l'idée plutôt géniale parce que ça a
bien réussi de cette nupes c'est lui qui
dit à 20 minutes c'était la semaine
dernière il dit que la fin de la nupes
est possible ce sont ces mots si elle
n'a pas de candidat commun aux élections
européennes or quand on écoute les uns
et les autres on a l'impression que
c'est quand même compliqué du côté de
laupes pour se mettre d'accord et
présenter une personnalité qui pourra
incarner et porter les couleurs de la
nupesse aux européennes et puis il y a
l'interview de Bernard Cazeneuve qui a
retenu votre attention pour vous c'est
lui le fossoyeur de la nups à l'ombre
c'est l'ex Premier ministre et le l'ex
ministre de l'Intérieur de François
Hollande il a été très clair il a dit
très simplement en 2027 il faudra
compter avec moi je serai candidat il a
pas utilisé cette phrase précisément
mais vraiment ces mots étaient très très
clairs encore une fois
et on ne sait pas encore sous quelle
bannière il va se présenter ben arcaz
neuf parce que c'est une figure tu
t'énerves du Parti socialiste mais enfin
il a lancé un nouveau mouvement qui
s'appelle la Convention il a dit
clairement que de toute façon il pourra
être à l'adversaire de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon si celui-ci veut encore y
retourner une quatrième fois après trois
défaites pourquoi pas en tout cas il
drague il drague l'argent parce que là
on parlait de droite mais alors Bernard
Cazeneuve il fait du pied à Fabien
Roussel le communiste qui ce matin
disait qu'il faut créer fonder un front
populaire plus large que la nupaisse
alors lui disait carrément d'aller à
droite donc vous voyez ça ratisse large
partout en ce moment et puis aussi il
fait un peu de coude à François Ruffin
tiens le bras droit quand même de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui ont le sang a
quand même des envies de liberté donc
oui la nuit pêche c'est fini c'est fini
Thomas et les meilleures analyses de
cette fin politique ne viennent pas du
macronisme comme on pourrait le penser
mais elles viennent de l'intérieur et
c'est Bernard Cazeneuve qui a un constat
il dit que cette alliance c'est
finalement fracassée sur deux choses le
culte de la personnalité de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et sur sa stratégie politique
stratégique qu'il a théorisé le bruit et
la fureur permanent comment faire
l'unité à gauche dit Cazeneuve quand on
ne cesse de diviser les Français de
façon aussi violente même constat ça
c'est intéressant autre personnalité du
PS voilà dissidente puisque lui aussi a
fondé son mouvement à refondation on va
l'écouter il était l'invité de la
matinale de Public Sénat le maire de
Rouen ce matin le maire de Rouen Nicolas
Mayer Rossignol écoutez bien le mot
qu'il utilise
le social populiste c'est quand vous
commencez à dire des choses pour flatter
un électorat pour flatter ou faire
croire à des Françaises et des Français
pour gagner des voix alors que vous
savez très bien que vous ne le ferez pas
demain exemple quand vous dites 60 ans
40 à nuit pour tout le monde je pense
que c'est dangereux parce que vous avez
beaucoup de Françaises et de Français
qui vont y croire et demain si nous
sommes en responsabilité et que nous le
faisons pas alors là c'est le pire et
c'est ça qui amène ensuite l'abstention
ou pire le vote vers l'extrême droite on
retrouve cette conclusion dans le
discours de Bernard Cazeneuve
ce n'est plus une dystopie on l'a vu
avec les conséquences du mouvement
contestataire au projet de réforme sur
les retraites c'est le RN qui a récupéré
finalement l'opinion publique française
donc on y est et alors quand on écoute
bien l'analyse de du maire de Rouen là
ce matin le social populisme ça peut
être une notion qui faudra regarder de
plus près et alors quelques minutes
après je regarde Twitter et je vois un
tweet d'Adrien katnas qui promet cette
retraite à 60 ans exactement les propos
du maire de Rouen c'est une illustration
peut-être parfaite donc de ce social
populisme pour finir Bernard Cazeneuve
et donc Nicolas Mayer rossignols sont à
mon sens les deux meilleures analystes
de cette fin politique de la nupes et
leur constats sont implacables il faudra
bien voir bien sûr comment ça va infuser
chez les électeurs de gauche alors oui
effectivement j'entends votre argument
mais j'avoue que pour l'instant j'ai un
peu de mal à voir un destin national à
Bernard Cazeneuve et vous Bruno codresse
pour commencer pour le moment en tout
cas en politique on sait qu'il faut être
prudent je parle des conséquences de
cette analyse c'est-à-dire que avec des
analyses aussi fines peut-être que ça
perturbe un peu le corps et électoral de
la gauche je ne parle pas d'un destin
il faut pas négliger quand même à gauche
la profonde aspiration à l'unité et le
constat que tire beaucoup d'électeurs
des impasses liés aux divisions
primaires populaires 2022 Christiane
taubir
beaucoup de militants sont à la fois pas
très contents du fonctionnement de la
nups mais en même temps disent on a
conservé nos sièges de députés les
différentes formations politiques ont pu
sauvegarder et le cœur de la nupesse le
fondement de la nupcesse et la
candidature unique dans les
circonscriptions et je ne vois pas très
très bien les députés qui ont été élus
en 2022 socialiste écologique communiste
insoumis dire bah maintenant chacun
retourne chez soi pour les élections
législatives il y a deux scrutins
mal on le sait déjà européen d'abord
des sièges pour le moment mal parti mal
parti européenne très compliqué parce
que la question de l'Europe divise à
gauche depuis de nombreuses années ça ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
et que c'est un vrai complexité de dire
on veut gouverneur ensemble et on n'est
pas d'accord sur l'Europe donc comment
faire coexister cette volonté d'unité de
stratégie commune avec une division sur
avec une division sur l'Europe le temps
d'autant plus compliqué que les
premières enquêtes de pignons qui ont
été publiées sur les intentions de vote
c'est un peu loin pour les européennes
montre que la stratégie de division
voilà n'est pas nécessairement plus
mauvaise ils font mieux séparément
vers vous ça peut être la nups une sorte
d'étoile filante de de cette décennie
politique attention la nuit pêche c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc comme on sait
que il est déjà en fond de côté le sujet
c'est un peu comme Emmanuel Macron c'est
qui pourrait succéder à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je trouve ça intéressant
Cazeneuve face du pied à François Ruffin
qui lui-même veut se présenter à la
présidentielle et qui dit qu'il est en
train de devenir plus soucieux des
institutions donc on a une déjà une
surenchère je voulais insister parce
qu'on en a peu parlé sur la question
écologique parce que la question de pas
faire liste commune elle est venue des
écologistes qui ont traditionnellement
toujours fait des bons scores aux
élections européennes parce que
l'échelle européenne est très bonne sur
la question du verdissement etc moi je
pense que le sujet c'est est-ce que les
socialistes qui sont dans la nupesse
comprennent ou alors intérêt et comment
est-ce qu'il pourrait imaginer de faire
par exemple liste commune avec les Verts
qui pour l'instant ne leur propose pas
mais on voit bien que les socialistes y
compris les élus à l'Assemblée comme
Valérie Rabault sont au fond divisés sur
la question de l'avenir à donner à la
nups et que les élections européennes
vont être fondamentales pour dire les
choses et oui mais on peut ne pas être
d'accord et en tirer une issue on peut
ne pas être d'accord et continuer à en
discuter pendant des pendant très très
longtemps et par rapport à ce que vous
disiez sur Bernard Cazeneuve se
positionner aussitôt sans expliquer par
exemple ce qu'on fait aux européennes
sans expliquer comment se positionne
ensuite dans le champ électoral me
semble être une erreur j'ai du mal à
imaginer qu'il puisse vraiment devenir
des chances à François Hollande
rappelez-vous oui mais en tout cas moi
moi je pense qu'il y a un vrai sujet sur
le fait de cette positionner de cette
manière et ensuite de ne pas en tirer
des conséquences très concrètes et puis
je voudrais terminer sur la question
écologique en rappelant que c'est un
enjeu qui mobilise la jeunesse qui va de
plus en plus nous mobiliser parce qu'il
y a une accélération sur ce sujet est-ce
que ça débouchera sur une issue
politique pour les verres pour l'instant
on ne le voit pas mais quand on place à
2027 il faut penser aussi les choses par
rapport au contenu oui mais il y avait
déjà une opportunité potentielle en 2022
parce que l'urgence écologique et les
enjeux de transformation de mutation ils
étaient déjà là ils ont pas réussi à
faire raison mais le sujet c'est
l'incarnation et ce qu'on trouve la
bonne incarnation est-ce que Bernard
intellectuel je pense que les Français
ne sont pas persuadés par un certain
nombre de discours qui relève du gadget
là où ils voient que les défis sont
majeurs et qu'il faut des politiques
cohérentes et pour rebondir ce que
disait Laetitia le problème de Bernard
Cazeneuve je trouve c'est que oui il
s'est bien décrire la situation mais
c'est aussi surtout dire ce qu'il n'est
pas dans les rarement élu en disant ce
qu'on n'est pas on est élu en proposant
quelque chose et l'équation elle est
difficile à détenir parce que la nuit
pêche ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a ce
côté transgressif dans un moment où les
gens ont perdu vous la crédibilité de la
parole est très affaiblie le simple fait
de réussir à capter l'attention ce que
vous dites un truc saisissant c'est déjà
un atout alors quand vous êtes très
mesuré modéré c'est respectable quand on
entend effectivement la critique sur le
social peu plus mais ça ne capte pas la
tension la nôtre oui parce que c'est
notre mais c'est pour ça il faudrait
qu'ils arrivent à tenir le manche par
les deux bouts en quelque sorte la
capacité à transgresser à proposer une
nouvelle c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure la démocratie française
elle aussi plombée par le fait que ce
capitaliste financière mondialisé on
voit bien qu'il est à bout de souffle il
ne satisfait plus les Français pape ils
veulent pas pour autant de la Révolution
ils veulent aller très chaud il y a pas
de discours là-dessus
quand on est du côté du socialisme on
doit parler de politique sociale on doit
pas se contenter de critiquer les autres
et moi je trouve qu'il y a une inité des
propositions portées sur les politiques
sociales on ne parle plus du tout de
politique sociale si ce n'est pour
adosser ça de nouvelles obligations il y
a un sujet de réinvestir cette question
les inégalités augmentent et donc
Bernard Cazeneuve qui nous convaincre
qu'il est vraiment socialiste et on
verra avec un dernier mot de conclusion
pour vous Bruno co 13 j'ai quand même
question est-ce que si alors il y a
beaucoup de si l'hypothèse d'impact de
gouvernement d'une coalition avec elle
est ce fait ça ouvre quand même un champ
politique à la social-démocratie à la
gauche clairement puisque d'une certaine
manière ça remet du clivage droite sur
la question des européennes et des
écologistes je suis prudent parce que on
voit qu'une partie d'électorat de Jadot
2019 est allé progressivement
progressivement rejoindre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à la présidentielle de 2022 et
les premières enquêtes qui ont été
réalisées d'intention de vote montrent
qu'en cas de liste séparés pour le
moment les écologistes ne font pas mieux
qu'une liste France insoumise donc sur
la sur les cales qui ont de l'écologie
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à cranté quand même
un certain nombre de
points dans le pignon c'est une
démocratie c'est la redistribution des
fruits de la croissance quand il y a pas
de croissance et même qu'on projette
qu'il y en ait plus comme les vers vous
redistribuez quoi ça montre bien que la
sociale démocratie c'est
intellectuellement mort en réalité par
rapport au monde avec un tel débat que
lucifices
à faire jouer on va terminer là-dessus
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat Lucie Schmidt
votre livre Emmanuel Macron à
contretemps et publié aux éditions
Bayard je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
public